NO. NO. YES.
>> AMY DID MYRON. MYRON, YOU GOOD, MAN?
>> RIGHT. And now you want to defend me. I'm sick >> No
way. Amy Dangerfield, Myron. Amy >> No. Oh, no. I don't
even regret my charges or convictions. I've made mistakes. I
learn from them. Sometimes I
>> I'm being told that Amy that Zena's crashing out on
Amy Dangerfield. So, I think we're going to go straight into
Amy Dangerfield got kind of exposed on this Brilliam account.
Relaify HQ, that's the one. And Amy Dangerfield got exposed.
And she got exposed. I think it was the Darius Zena clip, right?
Where she's making out with Zena in front of Darius and Relaigh.
That got put in there. And everybody
everybody was like making fun of her and she did a stream about
it and said, "Oh, yeah. It's like I have a checkered past and
all this [__] right?" And yes, it recently blew up
because of the Lauren DeLaguana interview. Either way, it's like
kind of blowing up now. And yeah, she's crazy. Dude, what a vibe.
Immediately I'm immediately sitting here like what a vibe. The
vibe is
The vibe is incredible immediately. Let's go. Zena's crashing
out. I don't even know how to start this because unfortu- Okay,
unfortunately I'm pissed off cuz I was at work. I was making
some cash, making some money.
After I do that, tell me why I get on the internet and people
are tagging me and all this [__] about this Amy Dangerfield
stuff. And apparently there's a clip of Sneako
saying, you know, it's a matrix attack.
And I'm like, >> "What is this?" So, I click a few things
and I see that people are calling me a liar. Okay, let's check
it out. >> many [__] times I've been called
a liar and then I have to pull up
I open my Twitter and it's this
First of all, I said this what, 2 years 2 or 3 years ago? Or
maybe it was 2 years ago. Maybe it was 1 year ago. I I know when
the [__] I first exposed it. Yes, we Amy
There's actually way more than just that. But okay, now I'm posting
screenshots where I have to
prove that once again, Sneako lied because what does Sneako do
but always lie and then get exposed and then say it's a matrix
attack.
This was in 2023. I have the receipts with the date and the time.
I have videos of us. No, I do not have videos of us. No revenge
at all. When I say I have videos, Okay, Zena. >> out. It's
us dancing. It's us getting drunk together. This was 2023. I
don't give a [__] if Sneako said it was cap because
there's text conversations not just between me and Amy. There's
text conversations between me and Sneako where he's asking me
to convince Amy to have a threesome. I have all of it.
and I'm just so tired of this whole thing of oh, I'm I'm lying
as if I don't have all the receipts every single time where we're
having these conversations.
Mind you, it's not a bad thing that
or that I helped him get multiple threesomes when we were dating.
Yeah, I'm a down ass [__] That was my You know, he
says he wants to [__] with me. I'm going to tell
I'll convince the [__] don't want to [__]
him. Obviously, I'm going to convince the girl
Zena is awesome. to [__] So she did because she likes
me. As you guys can see when we're an unmedicated manic episode,
right? No. Zena is Zena is perfectly capable of doing this. Like
totally fine. Like totally on the I think Zena Zena is really
People don't understand that Zena is like a fantastic streamer.
But like when she's on the level, she's a fantastic streamer.
She does crash out sometimes, but just her by herself like totally
leveled off, totally fine, she's incredibly entertaining. hanging
out with Darius after me and Sneako break up, Amy and I continued
to make out and enjoy, you
type things together because love me,
I love females. I love women. So, yeah, I like to get Me and
Sneako had probably like four or five threesomes. And there's
other women that are now married and in relationships that, you
know, we were trashing the [__] out in the bedroom
that are red pill conservatives
that are lying to their husbands
as if they're these tradwives. And it's
I don't know if Amy's doing that, to be honest with you. Like
I'm I'm pretty sure Amy was like, "Nah, I I had a past." I Did
she not? I thought she did a stream was like, "Yeah, I'm only
Christian now. I like have a pretty checkered past." If I like
a guy and I'm with him for a while and he's cute, okay, I'm not
ashamed of it. Let me finish talking cuz I don't even need to
go all the way in on this again because
that's what I was saying. Where am I? I don't even know where
the [__] I'm at. They're grifting this whole like
Okay, what happened is why I first ever said anything about the
threesome with Amy was because she snaked Destiny. When Destiny
was putting her on, helping her even get out in the industry
in the first place. The whole coper red pill scene she wanted
to get in. Destiny was putting her on. And she just randomly
started snaking him when number one, oh, over Pixie, when she
didn't even like Pixie. They talked [__] about each
other. They didn't even like each other. She wanted to move the
[__] away from them. And she didn't like Lauren either.
They were all beefing secretly. They were all beefing with each
other secretly. I have all those messages they were telling me
about it. Oh, they hate each other. Da da da. These were catty
ass hoes. They weren't friends. They were talking about who's
dirty, who leaves the apartment a mess cuz they all lived together
at one point. Now you coming for my friend? I'mma put your business
out there because you married that and you've been lying to that
and let me tell you when me and Sneako [__] this
hoe, it was only one week after her and her boyfriend had broken
One week, but you're this trad conservative woman? You talk about
women on OnlyFans? You couldn't even wait two months? At least
I wait two, three months before I [__] on some new
You didn't give your a break, hoe. And on top of that, before
me and Sneako [__] her, at this point I'll put everybody
out there. I owe nothing to none of these people. Myron, Fresh,
all these people that told me to be quiet when me and Sneako
first broke up and they wanted to defend Sneako and Osina don't
expose this. Osina don't do this. It's bad. It's bad. Blah blah
blah blah blah blah blah blah blah. Now Fresh and Sneako aren't
friends and Fresh is Oh yeah, Zena was right. Blah blah blah
blah blah. I don't owe Myron loyalty. I don't owe Fresh loyalty.
I don't owe none of these loyalty. I'm not under any NDA. Guess
what?
I have receipts on all these on the baby jewelry and I'm tired
of defending this god damn for lying and then when they're mad
it's By the way, Zena was right. Oh oh now I was right because
you guys are beefing. Now I was right and now you want to defend
me. I'm sick of that. But anyway,
before me and Sneako even
she had just not two days prior a different man. And I could
say who it is. I could actually just say who it is and I have
receipts of that as well. Wait. What? >> Right and now
you want to defend me. I'm sick of that. >> But anyway,
before me and Sneako even
she had just not two days prior a different man. And I could
say who it is. I could actually just say Oh, it's just a totally
different guy. Okay. Come on. START GET SAUSNICK IN THE MIX.
THROW A GRENADE at him, Sausnick. I'll say I'm red pill because
I agree with a lot of red pill stuff. But is it red pill about
being honest? I'm not saying I'm red pill because I'm conservative
or you know, I'm not a hoe. I don't need to be married to these
If I like a guy and the vibe is right and I want to [__]
him, I'm a grown ass woman. I will [__] him and I
don't give a [__] if the internet calls me a hoe.
I know what I'm doing with my Every man that wants to [__]
me doesn't get to [__] me. I choose who to [__]
gets to [__] this okay? And yeah, sure. Right now
it's 17. Cool. By the end of this year it might be 20. Honey,
it might be 30. If I find attractive men and I want to [__]
them, I will the [__] out of them because I can.
It's that simple. If you have to sit here and lie and grift and
pretend to be this holier than thou virtuous person, why are
you having sex in the first place? Maybe don't do it if you feel
shame. You should never do something in life that you regret
and feel shame for. I've made some dumb decisions. I don't regret
them. They are life lessons. I don't regret a god damn thing.
I don't regret
you totally felt regret for all of this at least.
Definitely that I've remembered. You can't just flip your principles
to nothing matters and go, "Well, actually you should never do
anything if it gives you shame." Sounds like you're sort of post
hoc rationalizing a principle that you never actually had. >> Right,
a relationship? Anyway, I don't regret my body. I don't regret
hell. I don't even regret my charges
or convictions. I've made mistakes. I learn from them. I You
should regret those, actually. You should You should regret those.
Yeah. Yeah. >> Sometimes I don't. And I need to make that
mistake Dude, no way. >> I don't even regret my charges
or convictions. I've made mistakes. I learn from them. Sometimes
I don't.
I don't feel bad about them, but I learn from them. But sometimes
I also don't learn from them. Fantastic stuff. >> And I
need to make that mistake two three more times. But guess what?
They're life lessons. I don't regret I don't feel shame for I'm
not embarrassed by I tell the world my business because ain't
nobody going to expose me. See, that's not a way to live. You
You're just describing like a permission structure to be a terrible
human being. But you know what? It is funny, so we let it go.
told you that? Oh, that's right. I did. The If I get a yeast
infection tomorrow, I'll go on there and I'll be like, "Damn,
guys, I got a yeast infection." If I catch STD, we're going to
talk about it. I'll be like, "Guys, I got a STD from this I'm
going I will be telling you because I'm an open book and I don't
give a [__]
Um but these people that care so much about what other people
think, so they sit there lying and grifting and doing all this
and then it comes out. Cap, hold on. Let me pull this up. Okay,
this one's not the blurred one. I'm sorry. Why are we having
this conversation? Why are we Say Murthy, "Haha, sounds good.
I'll text him back." Now. Yeah, thanks. Don't tell me to go or
blank. Oh.
I could see this being Myron, right? An N here potentially.
Uh I don't know though. I'm never going to tell anyone in my
entire life. Okay. Well, having this conversation. And this was
May of 2023.
2023, he made a whole He made a whole video about it. You can
Google it. You can Google it. There's facts, there's tweets,
there's everything. He was already a Muslim by the time me and
Sneako were dating,
Um yeah, I said don't tell him you Sneako or blank. There's another
person I'm never going to tell anyone in my entire life. Did
you tell your husband? Did you tell your husband? And then this
is just about me being like he thinks you're bi because you me.
He admitted that I you on stream and I'm like no. So my thing
is it's just you're not this trad life. >> Everyone knew
that one though. Come on man. Everyone knew that one though.
Come on man. Everyone knew that one though. Come on man. Everyone
knew that one though. Come on man. Everyone knew that one though.
knew that one though. Come on man.
Everyone knew that one though. Come on
You had a on a that was that was five years younger than you
and get pregnant because he had money so that you could be a
trad wife because you was getting treats out in these streets.
All these conservative women Carley thinks was a in the past
too. She was big black
>> We all knew this one though. This isn't new. We all
knew this one.
It's just she's not that attractive so she couldn't be that big
of a hoe. You know what I'm saying? Isabella
She's not ugly. Obviously she was at these college parties in
all these pictures in lingerie going to Diddy parties looking
like, you know, hoe. Hoe. Amy, hoe. That four people after her
breakup. Four. Since I met her on Fresh and Fit, four. No. No.
Yes.
>> Dude, Zena is so funny man. God, why can't she just
be a good person and keep the content like together for two seconds?
No. No. Yes. Hoe. That four people after her breakup. Four. Since
I met her on Fresh and Fit, four. No. No. Yes. Four.
But she's a trad wife. And they were only broken up for a week.
On top of that, here's another juicy thing. One of them that
she wait, hold on. That makes it Wait, four Wait, what?
Four dudes in a week. Okay, that's a That changes everything.
It's like four is not that many in a week. Oh.
That's a couple. That's a couple. >> She brought her current
husband around.
Does he know they were because why are you hanging around and
you with your husband?
Are you a cuck? Are you a Are you aware that that they If you
are aware and you're like, you know what, it's cool, it's business.
Okay, cool, whatever. Do you. If you weren't aware, then she's
a dirty, disgusting because that's nasty. Because if you and
your husband are in these spaces, you're on So, signal the Ice
Poseidon. Is it Harris talking Kimmi subtly right here? Okay,
okay. Hey, Ice doesn't always take Kimmi's side. >> And
you're in this industry, especially red pill, where men and women
are targeted the most and you know, they have to uphold themselves
the most, why the are you bringing your husband around you were
And also not having him aware so that the internet can call him
a and they can smash on him. You now represent your husband and
you look like a fool, so now your husband looks like a fool.
Like
That's your husband. If I'm with a man, I mean, all my boyfriends
know everyone I because I tell them I'll be like, oh, I pumped
her, I this guy did her. I'll tell them because that's what you're
supposed to do. Yeah, they hold it against me when we break up
like, her, she was this. Okay, whatever. At least you knew. At
least you didn't get blindsided. At least I didn't bring you
around and I was and have you clap hands with him and hang out.
Meanwhile, that like, damn, I was I had your girl bent over backwards.
I was on her back raw and you're marrying that.
You getting here clowned. Your husband's getting clowned because
you lied. That's weird. But you're a tradwife. I just I just
don't understand the grift of like I know I know red pill gets
you like notoriety, whatever the [__] it's called,
but why grift? You could easily just be honest and be like, yeah,
you know, I had this past and I feel like red pill actually changed
my mind and I feel like I wish I would have Is this about Isabella
or Amy? It's about everyone, okay? It's about Isabella, it's
about Amy, it's about everybody, all right? >> sooner because
I would have been a different person. Just let Zena cook, >> you
I don't know why Zena's going off. I think Zena just, you know,
she felt like she wanted to leak some stuff. Hopefully, she gets
in a flow and just starts leaking a bunch of other [__]
too. That's what I'm here for. I'm hoping that Zena will get
into a flow of like leaking [__] on Amy Dangerfield
and then just go like, "Also, you, you, you, you, you." Cuz that
tends to be what
>> happening, [__] On top of that, you didn't
stop after me and Nico you were still coming around. You was
about to [__] me and Darius. She just didn't really
like Darius and then I was getting to know him and I was like,
"Yeah, no, I don't want to give this man a threesome and like
you know, we're just getting together." Like, "No, he didn't
earn that yet." But as you guys can see from those clips, we're
obviously making the [__] out full Oh,
>> wonton action. She was very comfortable because and
and also, I mean, her [__] was pretty. It is pink.
It tasted nice. It was clean. It wasn't nasty. She didn't stink.
None of that. It It was nice. Like, I'm not one of those I don't
have to sit here and lie be like, "Oh, she had a drink that stank
dirty dirty This is very weird now. Thank you, Zena. She's doing
She's doing her live forever guy impression, okay? Actually,
her microbiome was top 1% of all the If you If you guys are interested
to >> Does she got a cute Yes, the [__] was
nice. But back to what I was saying.
No! [__] this And then going on the internet, going
on all these podcasts, bringing him around men you were already
It just It just makes it easier to [__] on you people.
Like, it just makes it easier to [__] on you. And
the sad part is is when you're getting mugged and [__]
on by an OnlyFans witch, that makes it worse. It's like, "Damn,
so that's This is who's carrying Red Pill? This is what the Groypers
were all championing or championing? Oh my god! Oh my god! Conservative
white woman." She's a
She's a
I hate to break it to you, Zena. The Groypers assume all of the
all of like the right-wing tradwives who are who have a social
media presence, they assume they're all That's like the assumption
until proven otherwise. As in, yes, you need to prove the negative.
We will just call you a forever, actually. There is no winning.
There's literally no winning. You are a as soon as you enter
those spaces. And then if you die without ever being exposed
as a then they're like, well, you know, exception proves the
rule. That's how it works, man. >> Nothing wrong with it.
It's the only thing wrong with the lying part.
I don't even know what a I like Nick Fuentes, he's funny. That's
about it. I don't really give a about any of it, but it is what
it is. Oh, there's a A ho is a ho. Y'all call I don't really
call it a but that's what you guys will label any woman that
isn't a virgin is a So, that's why we're saying that. Is she
And to be honest, because she lied, I feel like there's a lot
more going on than even I know. Because she's clearly lying.
Like what the I tell you who I I genuinely don't give a It's
not a flex. Sneako was hot. Yeah, I was him for a while. Okay?
He was hot. I liked it. There's a couple people that I clearly
was very attracted to and I was like, yeah, let me bag that.
And I bagged it. Okay, I might have a male mentality in a female's
body, but I like it. So, yeah, it's a flex for me. Y'all >> You're
amazing. Thank you for this. Um yeah, I'm a trumper. I'm not
red pill. Yeah, if I like somebody like a celebrity and I'm like,
you know, I want that and I get it, it's a flex for me. I don't
give a Call me a then baby, I'm a Call me Marilyn Monroe cuz
she was a too. And you know what? This is totally unscripted,
by the way. Zena can just rant like this for like hours.
Straight up hours. She can rant like this without taking a single
breath or pausing at all. Just like infinite. It's it's infinite.
It will come out forever.
That's got her places, so I'm going to start getting my place.
Anyways, back to what I was saying. I just think it's like, I
don't know, man. It's just it's totally insane.
It's totally insane. And And the only reason I'm so offended
is, why the would you try to come for me and call me a liar knowing
I got the receipts?
I don't just talk out my ass. Wait, did Amy call her a liar?
I didn't see that. Did Amy Dangerfield come out and say Zena
was wrong on this?
Did she come out and say like, oh, actually Zena's just making
this up or somebody's just making this up? And not have proof.
I feel like that almost certainly didn't happen. I feel like
maybe at best, you might have gotten a tweet like this is wrong
or
Yeah, yeah, I feel like I feel like Zena takes it as so if she
if you say that something she knows is true is false, even if
you're calling somebody else a liar, I think I feel like sometimes
Zena is just like, oh, I got you. I I'll get you right now, okay?
I'll prove that this is Sneako did? Oh.
Oh, well, Sneako did? Uh-oh.
Unlucky. Expose all the grifters?
You know what? I have files on these people. And the reason I
have files now is I heard some [__] when Ice Poseidon
said he had files on everybody, I got inspired. I was like, yo,
this guy is actually psychotic.
Maniacal? Is that what it's called? Maniacal? I like I was kind
of on Ice Poseidon until I found out he was a total psychopath,
and then I was like, dude, that's awesome. >> And I was
just like, but he's very smart.
Him and Kimmy are very smart people. And when I hear him talk
about the files he has on people in the confidence, I'm like,
you know what? Boom. So, what did I start doing? Archiving. I've
made my own files on people. Especially these red pill grifters,
okay? So, I have the files, too. Um Marilyn died at 36, near
your age. Cool, I can die at 36. I'll Six more years, cool. I'll
be out of this. Thank you. World's going to [__]
anyway. We got virgin roipers running around here champagning.
Does she think when people say champagning, they mean champagning?
Champagning? They're champagning a Getting married to people,
bringing them around. They was Yeah, bro, that's fine.
How you attract, but ain't red pill? I'm not red pill because
I don't agree that
you know, men can [__] anyone and women need to be
virgins. I I I don't agree. I think people should What's happening?
Uh Zena has exposed that Amy Dangerfield was a bit promiscuous
after her previous breakup, and that she had a threesome with
Amy Dangerfield and Sneako. Uh maybe more than one. And she said
no, she said more than one threesome with with Amy Dangerfield
before. That's what it is. >> Should do whatever the people
want to do. Because I think Sneako called her a liar. She said
she said Amy, but did she say Virgil? I think she said Virgil.
>> bringing them around cuz they was Yeah, bro. That's
fine.
How you a Trump but ain't red-pilled? I'm not red-pilled because
I don't agree that um
you know, men can anyone and women need to be virginal. I I don't
act Virginal.
>> I think people should do whatever the people want to
do, but be safe about it, be honest about it, and harm none.
Um that's it. So I I don't know. I don't know what what you want
to call that, but like generally, I don't think I need to rush
and get married and have babies. That's not what's on my mind.
I like making money. And yeah, like I'm talking to someone. Sometimes
I talk to two people. Um and if I decide, you know what? It's
going well, I might crack. Then I might crack. I don't want to
be confined to this oh, I'm loyal to this person because I'm
committed to them, but now this hot attractive person who might
be my dream guy is suddenly hitting me up like, "Hey, we haven't
talked in a while. Like I really like you. Can I see you?" So
yeah, my dumb ass ignored the man of my dreams.
Darius. And then after that, I ended up a some random young dude
just because he had young and I was like, "You know what? He
easy. He'll let me do whatever I want. I can get all my kinks
out. I can literally run this in the bedroom." So yeah, okay
guys. Y'all want to call me a groomer? Then call me a groomer.
I had a young It was decent. I could whenever I wanted. He did
whatever I wanted to. And you know, it boosted my confidence
because Darius was being a [__] and I didn't want
to [__] him anymore. And this dude was on the other
guy was on my for about a year. So I was like, "You know what?
I get some fresh young Let me fish out this dude." And it was
fine. I had my fun. Who gives a He was 19. Yeah, he was legal.
He was legal. And I don't give a I genuinely do not give a She's
obviously talking about ShoeB, yes. She's obviously talking about
ShoeB.
I Okay. She's She's like going crazy. Here, I'm going to restart
this cuz otherwise, if we
if we don't restart this soon, it's going to end. And I don't
want to get over on the time section. >> give a Here we
go. We're good. Continue. >> hot dude which they do. I
I got DMs.
will [__] them. I don't care. Make it illegal then.
Make it illegal. I'm 30 years old, dumb
I was 29 at the time. I'm 30. Ban these Just get these about
the chat. 30 and 19 is weird. Yeah, y'all don't be saying that
when you're in the same comments being like, "Get a fresh 18-year-old
girl. They're virginal." That's what you guys be
But when I [__] the fresh virgin who's 19, it's a
problem cuz I'm a woman. Yeah, that's the whole point of the
everything they're talking about, yeah. It's like the whole point.
They want men to be like considered better. That's like everything
they talk about, yeah. You know that, though. >> Grown
ass man, "Oh, it's different. It's different." A grown ass man
wants a virgin 18-year-old, it's a Oh, it's okay. I don't give
a about your standards. I will do whatever the [__]
I want for me. If you don't like it, all right, do something
about it.
Go protest. Start a Zena protest. Keep Zena away from the fresh
18-year-old men who want to [__] her. Go do a protest.
I'll come to it. I'll come to the protest. Go ahead and do it,
[__] I don't give a [__]
moving on from that, yeah. I do my thing. I don't sit here and
virtue signal and grift. Clearly, I act ratchet sometimes, a
lot of the times. Um I'm a very free bird. Like, I just do whatever
the [__] I want to do because first of all, there's
no rules to this. Why the [__] should I police myself
because No Sleep, uh Zinc, uh Who's this person? Mac 11, uh Chelsea
Billup, names I will never remember or even pronounce don't like
what I'm doing with my life.
Are you paying my bills? Are you going to make my life happy
for me? Are you going to help me to reach uh Nirvana?
The [__] Hey, I learned about Nirvana the other night.
We were talking about Buddhism and some some voice chatters
I didn't really know anything about Buddhism before that. I don't
think Zena does, either. I feel like Zena knows nothing about
Nirvana.
Are you? Yeah, I'm just reading Trench Foot Andy groomer. Oh,
okay. Trench Foot Andy said I was a groomer. I need to go re-evaluate
my life because Trench Foot Andy who probably lives in his mom's
basement, who probably has on his computer, who's probably overweight
and never even touched a female with consent other than their
younger sister um thinks I'm living life wrong.
Like Mickey makes sense. I'mma do what the [__] I
want to do.
And you don't have to like it. You generally don't have to like
it. Y'all mad cuz I So what? They asked me for it. They asked
me for it and I have messages where we talk about it. They asked
me for it. Are we're [__] shaming now because they
don't want me to [__] him in the ass with his own
mold? That's a problem?
That's still Shoe V by the way. That's still Shoe V. She's just
taking shots at Shoe V. Poor Shoe V. Poor Shoe V. SOMEBODY CHECK
ON Shoe V. Support for Shoe V is critical right now. >> Oh my
god, I'm so sorry. I'm so sorry. I told the world I ate a ass
for the first time because he begged me to give him a He ate
my and then he wanted to So I ate his ass. I told the world,
yeah, I ate this dude's I don't give a [__]
You should though. That's like someone else's privacy. It's kind
of [__] up. >> I don't give a [__]
I tried it. Yeah, I tried it. I was in a relationship with the
dude. Yeah, I ate it, bro. I did. I certainly did. Will I do
it again? Maybe if I'm in a relationship again and my dude really
wants it and says, "Yo, I want this." I'm going to do it. I'm
going to do it. Wow. Where Where is the boy Sam? No, it wasn't
Sam Bon. I didn't even date Sam Bon. I think we only had sex
like three times. It was very vanilla. Like if Sam Bon was not
a freak. Look, I'mma be honest, bro. Amy did Myron. Myron, he
can't get mad. I I I owe nobody loyalty anymore because he lies
and lies and says he has a restraining order which he does not
have because the case was dismissed and I posted those receipts.
Myron didn't have my back.
Fresh didn't have my back. Chris didn't have my back. Nobody
had my back. When Tico lies and says the FBI were after after
me, they never were. Like you can literally go to Miami Dade
and search her name. By yourself, you guys search my cases all
the time. Miami-Dade Clerk, Amara Samson, you can see it was
literally dismissed because of failure to appear. Somebody made
a account that said I was going to stab Sneako or some [__]
when I was already dating the Darius. Like what the Um anyway,
and he had no other evidence other than a random screenshot that
somebody else made. So, I think the boy was just embarrassed
to be like, "Amy did him too." And she brought her man around
him. Amy brought her husband around Myron in front Amy Dangerfield,
Myron. Amy Dangerfield. >> No. Oh, no.
Oh, no. That They are you
You brought your man around a woman. >> That woman. That
woman. That woman. I need a I need a fantastic Myron for the
B-word, and I just can't I just keep I It just comes out, man.
I I can't do anything about it. >> Oh my god, W gropers.
W gropers. W gropers. W gropers. W gropers. W gropers. And I
can say a lot more. My ex-husband Myron That's not exposing Myron.
Myron is red-pilled almost every [__] he puts on
the podcast down here. And he says it. Myron got how many hoes?
You think Myron gives a I don't think Myron gives a I genuinely
don't. Myron's how many people are on there? And also, I don't
care if he's met my father. He's not my man. I'm never that man.
And I got proof of that, too. Um yeah, I respect Myron, but but
at the same time, like did he have my back? Is anybody defending
me when Sneako tries to call me a liar? No. So, I don't give
a [__] I don't give a [__] about these
that actually are liars, that actually sit there and lie and
grift. I don't care. I don't care. So, I'm not exposing a guy
that already publicly says he sleeps with a lot of the women
that he like talks to on the show. Um I mean, that's literally
that's a W for him. He He likes to do that. Myron, for example,
I respect because Myron out of everybody in the red pill space,
Myron is the only one that actually lives how he preaches. In
somewhat. In somewhat. Obviously, they talked about like all
the girls, but even Myron says like he'll still [__]
them recreationally. He does and he does use them recreationally.
He does He does go out there and you know, slime these hoes.
Yeah, he never said he was a good Muslim. Sneako grifts being
this Muslim, but he's still out there doing drugs and is not
married. How you How you been Muslim for 3 years you still ain't
found a wife? Wasn't the whole point of like him going on that
world tour when it was love speech and he was going on the world
tour it was supposed to find a place to raise kids and find a
wife. Did he never do that? No, instead he came the [__]
back to America to more on stream and do drugs over there. That's
it. So.
I don't know. They're all grifters, bro. They're all grifters.
What happened to that Who was that one guy who who wore the diaper?
What was his name? Like MLD or something like that who got exposed
as another Zerk is just a warlock. I kind of I kind of was about
to say Turkey Tom and I feel bad for that cuz that's like that's
the you know. I should I shouldn't be saying that >> Zerk
is not a grifter. Zerk is just crazy and he's a warlock. The
only thing he grifts is being Catholic. He's a warlock. Zerk
does black magic. I've always said this and I will always say
it. He does black magic. That's why he has a great understanding
of the occult. That's why we've always bumped heads because he
does do black magic. Zerk had a holy Bible with scribblings all
over it and he would put people's name in shut them into the
Bible, okay? There were pages of the Bible burnt off of it and
folded over with people's names and writings in it and everything.
Ask Heel Mike. Ask Heel Mike. Zerk does black [__]
magic. If Sneako was a good Muslim then he should face the 100
lashing punishment for sin when not married. Praise Allah.
Exactly. He should just do that. He should do a stream where
he takes the 100 lashes for every Well, I've heard If you guys
don't know her whole thing about Zerk, she said this about Zerk
like 100 times, right? She has said this about Zerk like 100
times. So, that's not a new one for me. That might be new for
you guys, though. Yeah, that's She talks about Zerk doing black
magic all the time. You know, being a Muslim. It'll probably
be a couple thousand lashes, but just do it. Do a stream. Everybody
will watch it and then you'll be vindicated and then it'll be
fine. But don't sit there and say the matrix is attacking you.
The matrix don't give a [__] about you. If the matrix
isn't attacking you then I'm the matrix. I am the matrix because
you're a liar. You're a liar. The old Sneako was cool as [__]
The old Sneako before this grifting Islam was creative, talented,
cool. Like that Sneako was amazing.
This new Sneako that's grifting all this [__] is
insane.
Insane. Like >> I miss the old Sneako. The old Sneako didn't
give a [__] The old Sneako did not give a [__]
The old Sneako was cool. This Muslim Sneako is a lie. It's not
real. I'm just saying people talk I'm just talking about the
lies. I don't think Sneako himself is a bad person. I don't think
he's he's 100% not gay. People be like, "Oh, he's gay." He was
a model. He's extremely attractive. He's extremely talented.
He is actually very very very very very smart. Um yeah, like
I said, talented, creative, all of that. 100% give that man his
flowers.
But him grifting this Muslim thing, I guess that was a smart
move because he wanted to go more viral and to get bigger and
he knew that the Islam like community would carry him. Yeah,
you're not wrong. If he Yes, they look the they look exactly
the same. Zena should go and find him.
Zena's about to go and find out who Abus X is, okay? He's going
to be very in She's going to be very into Abus X. But at the
same time, it just ruined a lot >> Sneako Mia Hoffman from
Fousey's dating show. He had Sneako on there. There's a clip
on Twitter of Fousey exposing this.
I got timed out for saying Muslims BTW soft ass mods girls in
person.
Okay, don't talk about Islam. We're not here to talk about Islam.
Don't talk about Muslims. That's why the mods timed you out.
You have no reason to come in here and disrespect a religion.
>> Oh, I need to I need to be very careful about TTS. I
think the TTS could be a problem, all right? I need to be very
careful. You'll be watching.
He's not following. He's not following what he preaches or >> Are
you still on good terms with Destiny? Did C tell you to stop
talking to Destiny? Can you expose one more trad
Well, pick the Anna trad clearly. I mean, she already got exposed
on video. This is like the kind of thing that Zena is like a
See, Zena's like obviously By the way, that shouldn't shock you.
Zena's been a despicable person this entire stream. We're watching
somebody despicable do despicable things. You can't just get
mad when they do it to somebody that you care about, right? Obviously,
Zena's been despicable the whole time. She's been leaking details
about people the whole time. So, if you're going to get mad about
this one, you should have gotten mad about all the other ones,
too. We just love that the women that talked about, you know,
strippers and only fans is like, I'm over here like, "Yeah, I
do this. We're here cuz there's a messy person being a terrible
human being and leaking a bunch of [__] okay? >> And they
need to be talking [__] and it's like, y'all hoes
be so conservative, but you're the ones you got to watch out
for. At least I'll tell you who I'm I'll tell you what I'm
I wear my
You forgot to mention Low Tier God. Bro said he cracks. Also,
any dirt on
Would I [__] Low Tier God? Um is he single right
now? Yeah, I'll probably That would be the second black man I
I would consider Yes, I I would [__] Low Tier God.
I think he's hot. I've said this before. He's a fine ass
Okay? Did I meet him yet? No. If I do meet him, chances are if
the vibes are right, maybe we do
Okay? I'm telling you right here right now. Second Yeah, cuz
I'm one black man. Um but anyway, like I I don't I'm not going
to sit here and and and lie. Like what? I posted the messages,
bro. I've literally shared the messages. Why would it be lies?
Why Like this is the thing. Y'all will look at the facts, y'all
will look at the receipts, and you guys will literally gaslight
yourselves into believing whom like dumb [__]
I will hold two bottles of water in front of your face and say,
these are two bottles of water, and y'all will
one is probably not even actually water. One is probably not
actually a bottle. Like is that how stupid you are? Is that how
stupid you are?
Back to what I am saying, yeah, Amy's a liar, guys.
And I I've just When I first said the stuff, like when I first
tweeted about the threesome thing, like I don't even know when
that was, like maybe last year. I got Isn't she married? Yeah,
but this is before she was married. So it is just it's I think
the criticism is that Amy Dangerfield does like the trad larp
right now, right? When she's got a very very very very very not
trad past.
And is not was not transparent about it until quite recently.
>> from people at Fresh and I never met Convos. What the
[__] You're talking about people I've not even met
yet. Like what? And then you talk about people that I don't even
I don't even
I don't even remember they exist. You bring up people that I
don't remember even exist. Anyway, I got hit up from people at
Fresh and Fit with her husband or something like that and we're
like, >> Sneako only went Muslim because of Andrew Tate
going Muslim first. Dude don't have an original thought in his
peanut brain. >> Yeah, it was literally because of Andrew
Tate. Yeah. We all know this. He was um copying everything that
Tate did.
Literally. But that's what I was saying. So you found him cool
because he was an Andrew Tate clone then. That he wasn't cool
or original. She's like, "Sneako is so awesome like what he was
before the Muslim thing? Cuz cool and original and great." It's
like, "Uh
no. You You literally just described him as a an Andrew Tate
clone.
So you're not saying that at all. No. They hit me up and they
asked me to delete the stuff and not expose the Amy stuff cuz
I think they were like somebody was collabing with the I can't
really remember. I got hit up with one of their little peoples
or whatever. All right, it was Icey. At the time Icey hit me
up she was like, "Hey, can you delete this? Amy and and her husband
are together. They got married and they're working around with
Fresh and Fit and Myron and them and da da da da da and it's
going to start drama." and I was like, That's what I said. I'm
like, "Girl, I don't work for them." She talked [__]
about Destiny and then Icey was like, "I'm just letting you know,
you do you." But yeah, they did try to you know, they did hit
me up talk about I should delete
that happened then and I did out of respect but now I just I
don't I just don't give a [__] about none of these
people who don't support me or help me with a god damn thing
when I'm in a bind. They're not doing [__] to talk
about help me with out with any [__] thing. So it's
like, why why do I need to keep showing people loyalty that ain't
loyal to me? That's that's what I Um how can anyone have proof
of lie when you literally have proof of messages that makes no
sense. Well, that's what I'm saying and there's more conversations
at that which I can literally post on Twitter but it's like,
"Damn, then I'm going to be going in again." Then it's like,
I think I get tired from all this yapping. Dude, it's it's good.
Listen,
I like Zena's content. Zena Zena's content is good when she's
just like yapping to a camera solo. Especially when she's like
letting stuff flow, letting drama happen, okay? >> I'm
going to do this whole thing crashing out again and I'm posting
all these videos and receipts again.
Mind you, I have a picture of Sneako holding the Quran. Literally
not 3 days after he finished out the Amy with me and he's with
Zerkaa. Like, Jesus Christ. Jesus Christ. These [__]
are fun tea.
These are fun tea.
which I think Destiny exposed this before, when when Destiny's
ex-wife Melina was there
and I won the the e-date thing, he was trying to convince me
to get Melina to have a threesome with us. And I told Destiny
cuz I was like, "Bro, that's actually crazy." But he was like,
"Actually, I have those messages. I might as well post those
too. I might as well post them for real." Yeah, why not? You
know what? Zena, go nuts. Go nuts, Zena. Like, she likes you.
She literally likes you. Um someone made this, me, Sneako, and
another girl that I convinced to have a threesome with me and
Sneako. Like, y'all forget like, I mean, then they're like, "Oh
my god, you were Sneako's just laying." These were adults. These
were adults. But yeah, I'm a hot like all this stuff I'm like
me and my [__] one of And I like stuff like I like
stuff like But when you're going to go grift and then suddenly
act like you're this um, you know,
trad wife and then then start snaking people, it's like, okay,
now we got a problem cuz you're weird as and you're a liar. Um
and I don't do that. I'm sorry. You know, listen.
Well, I just want to show you guys videos from that day, May
17th, you know, us in the club with Amy. And it's me and Amy
with Sneako the whole time. Look, I'm making her dance on me.
I'm grabbing her. There's Sneako. There's Sneako. I am a because
he's like There's Zena getting to work. Getting my [__]
for me. Yeah, because here I am with Amy right there in the red.
It's just messy, man. I'm grabbing her up. I'm making her bend
over on me. Look, I stood her up. I made her bend over and twerk
on me. And here's Sneako watching like the He is like, "Yeah,
Zena about to get me some tonight." And sure sure thing. And
then he got caught. And then Chris caught him. He's like, "Oh,
that's very Muslim of you." He's like, "No, no, no. No, no, no.
Don't record me. No, no, no. Don't record me. Don't record me.
Don't record me, Chris." Like, I got it all. And here's me and
Amy getting gay as fun of Sneako. Y'all forget like I have
Oh bro, I always have receipts. And that's the thing. I just
hate my mother Oh my god, me with the twins. No, I didn't [__]
them unfortunately. I would love to though. I love them. They're
so hot, but no, they weren't [__] Uh so I didn't
[__] them, but Oh, here we go again. Us being gay.
Here's Sneako. I'm [__] them tonight. I'm [__]
them tonight. Yeah, that's a that's your trad wife for you by
the way, getting all frisky on me in the club. Get the [__]
out of here. These These
Listen, if a [__] is online claiming I straight up
don't understand why Zena's doing this to Amy.
Like I didn't I have not seen Amy call her a liar. I saw Sneako
call her a liar or I saw Sneako being like I this isn't real.
This isn't real. But why why is she just going hard on >> She's
a conservative trad wife. Just know SHE'S NOT.
I WAIT, I KNOW why she's Oh, right. We answered that ourselves.
No, no, no. She She either says it directly or she says it after.
It's the the Destiny hip hippies, right? That Destiny leaked
this about her, that she's doing this cuz she's close with Destiny.
Right. >> She's not, bro. That These red pill women are
not real. It's literally just for clicks and views because Right?
Cuz that's the that's where the allegation comes from is somebody
posted a clip. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Destiny said that Amy Dangerfield
Sneako and then it became a threesome after that, right? That's
where that's where she jumped in. Unfortunately, a lot of red
pill viewers are like these little virgin griper incels and they
just think, "Oh, a wholesome conservative woman." And they are
sick. Well, I mean she might have some other reason. I'm just
saying that makes sense to me cuz she's said She said in this
rant that she really likes
And then it was Destiny who made the original allegation.
And I just wonder if like that's I I do feel like she actually
talks about that that hippies. She was like, "You You want to
make a hip piece on my friend? [__] you." She said
that in this. I've watched it already. >> sucking for it.
They sent for it. And these women, as you know, we are women.
We are naturally predatorial.
We see them as prey. It is so easy. That's why I cried on the
podcast so many times because it's so easy to reel them in in
and be like, "Oh yes, I regret my mistakes on OnlyFans."
Ma'am regrets making a whole bunch of
Stop. It just brings them in like, "Babe, let me give you money
so you can get out of this. You don't have to do this." Or the
red pill [__] and it's like, "Oh, I'm so conservative.
I'm a tradwife. I want you to find a good husband. We need more
women like you." And they get gassed up in the head with it cuz
they like it. That's all it is. You're just preying on these
incel boys who are who don't get who sit on the internet talking
[__] about women. Your tears are real though. Yeah,
I'm an actress. I can literally cry for you right now. Look how
quick. Look at that. There you go. You see how quick I can cry
for you? Stop playing. Stop playing. I am a dangerous woman.
But the the only thing about it is I tell you who I am. Like
You see that? You see that tear? Stop. I'm not even talking about
anything sad and I got a tear rolling down my cheek while I'm
crinched.
Come on. I'm I'm actually I Dude, you guys think I'm emotional
right now? I'm totally in control. Look, I have a tear rolling
down my face. I'm totally in control. And there's a tear rolling
down my cheek. I'm an actress.
Don't ever say my tears are real, baby, cuz if it's on the internet,
I promise you I'm doing it for a reason. It's on purpose. When
I'm crying off stream, those are real. Well, sometimes. Cuz sometimes
I practice crying. But uh yeah, if I'm showing the internet if
I'm showing the internet
obviously I want the internet to see it. Are you Are we dumb?
Are we dumb? Are we
I'm done. I'm done. I'm done. I'm done. I'm done. I'm done.